during the agriculture and Fisheries
council meeting the Italian presidency
presented his work program for the next
six months no pay some of elementary put
their these months we want to put a
message out to the European public
opinion want to show them the agro-food
sector and the fishing sector are
crucial for building a new economy in
this continent a policy debate was held
on organic farming one of the main
priorities of the presidency most of the
Member States welcomed the Commission's
intention to simplify the rules for
organic production and to raise consumer
confidence regarding organic products
however there were concerns that new
proposed rules would drastically change
the current legislation and constitute a
risk to growth in the organic sector the
future of the milk sector following the
abolition of the milk quota system in
2015 was also on the agenda for the
moment the regulatory framework based on
the 2008 political agreement about the
end of the milk quota regime has been
confirmed ministers were briefed and
held exchange of views on a commission
communication on fishing and total
allowable catches for 2015 most member
states acknowledged the global
improvement of the state of the fish
resources besides improving
environmental protection the new Common
Fisheries Policy will allow a better
sustainable management of the resources
and a better profitability for fishermen
you
you